pourquoi merci de m'avoir répondu c'est
bien je suis ravi d'être ici autant sur
le thème des nourritures terrestres
ça fait trois mois que je faisais de la
recherche sur ce thème j'ai retravaillé
le texte
maintes fois pour que chaque mon compte
j'ai même pris des cours de diction
puis hier j'apprends que ce toc doit
être enfoncé et doux du coup ça tombe
très mal parce que je ne suis pas du
tout quelqu'un qui excelle à faire des
choses à la dernière minute ce qui est
dommage car c'est souvent à la dernière
minute que j'arrive à me motiver
assez pour le faire par exemple
j'attends la dernier minute au moment où
je crève la dalle pour sortir une pizza
cieux gelais de congélateurs et là je
vois qu'il faut attendre 30 minutes de
condé congélation et ses trente minutes
après ça que je vois je lis sur la ligne
suivante qu'il faut préchauffer le four
pendant 12 minutes
ok donc du coup j'ai passé toute la
journée hier à l'ira sur des sites
comment faire en beauté toc en français
j'ai appris que c'est bien de commencer
avec une citation
alors voici je crois ce que je dis je
fais ce que je crois
victor hugo voilà la citation c'est fait
ah j'ai appris aussi que il faut
employer de l'adverbe le maximum
possible pour avoir l'air intelligent
alors j'ai fait une liste d'adverbes
afin d'être sûr d'avoir le minimum
syndical alors effectivement absolument
assidûment méticuleusement
intrinsèquement voilà ça c'est fait
aussi et bien sûr il faut faire beaucoup
de pauses afin d'accentuer le propos
mais la chose primordiale pour faire un
bon discours en français hélas tous les
avis sont unanimes c'est de parler
français
du coup j'ai passé toute la nuit
dernière à apprendre la langue française
je me suis arrêté à l'aube au chapitre
sur le subjonctif
alors je m'excuse d'avancé je ne le
crois pas ok c'est un peu chiant parce
que moi je ne suis pas francophone a la
base je sais que vous dites oui on sait
c'est à cause de mon accent je parle pas
vraiment comme ça ok je parle peu comme
les québécois dans le sens qu'on n'a pas
besoin de sous titres mais si j'en à
embellir tu vois ce genre d'action est
souvent mes amis américains il me
demande si après 12 ans en france
si maintenant je rêve en français parce
que apparemment ça c'est le signe qu'on
est complètement bilingue mais non je
rêve toujours en anglais mais maintenant
je cauchemarde en français et je dis ça
parce que le ton qu'on passe dans un
nouveau pic on ne parle pas la langue
correspond un peu à l'âge social qu'on
nous donne si tu parles comme un bébé tu
sera traité comme un bébé
ok et quand on arrive dans ce nouveau
pays
on est comme un nouveau né on est
fragile on est ouvert à tous et on peut
au curry nez sur son voisin dans un
restaurant et tout sera pardonnée ok
histoire véridique manquer d'eau mon
premier vol new york paris je faisait
des exercices dans mon livre de langue
française de base comment fais-tu ce qui
se préparait pour le monde qui
l'attendait en bo2 neuvirth un peu dans
un avion c'est un peu comme le neuf mois
qu'on passe dans le ventre de sa maman
on n'a pas assez de place pour étirer le
jambes la nourriture vient vers nous et
c'est déjà pré mâchées et on entend une
voix masculine est source d'un an qu'on
ne voit pas et qui nous parle de choses
qui ne sont pas du tout adaptés à un
autre niveau de compréhension
j'ai pris des cours intensifs de
français le lendemain de mon arrivée sur
le territoire français mais ça m'a pas
trop aidé parce que la langue française
c'est comme des mains plus on apprend -
c'est facile
bien sûr il y a deux règnes bizarre
qu'on découvre la première semaine comme
le fait que chaque nom
et soit masculin soit féminin et tout ça
à automne logique quand tableau de
salvador dali hockey et le fait qu'il y
à deux lettres à la fin de mot que vous
pensez pas de tout je sais pas pourquoi
vous voulez m je sais pas peut-être
c'est google pour gagner au scrabble
je sais pas où le voyais elle ne voyait
nasale parce que pour le bien prononcé
il faut être propriétaire d'un château
dans la vallée de la loire
mais quand on creuse on découvre
d'autres choses gênantes comme le fait
qu'en français l'article qui précède un
ânon correspond aux gens du nom et pas
au sexe de la personne qui en est
propriétaire
je m'explique par exemple en anglais aux
10,4 c'est à dire le chapeau 2 l mais
parce que le mot chapeau en français et
masculin vous dites son chapeau du coup
ça résout pas le problème de qui
appartient ce [ __ ] de chapeau on se
parle pas répond qu on dit martin lève
la main en hongrie on dit martin on
précise qu il s en main ou plutôt sous
main parce que martin est un garçon
parce que sinon je me demande quelle
main ines martin est-ce que c'est celle
des élèves à sa droite françois et
xavier qui s'est endormi pendant le
cours d'histoire ou peut-être c'est la
main à couper que martin a trouvé dans
la dos remplis sont devant la maison de
monsieur chenonceaux ne bouchait xulu
qui pue la cacasse de faux on sait pas à
qui cet acquis c'est cette fameuse
m'ennuie martin 9
en français on peut pas savoir ma
difficulté d'apprendre le français vient
certainement du fait que je suis née à
new york des parents argentins avec des
origines allemandes et autrichiennes
ça veut dire que
mes parents parler une langue maternelle
différentes de leurs parents que moi je
parle une autre langue maternelle que
mes parents et aujourd'hui mes enfants
parlent une autre langue maternelle que
moi en gros dans ma famille on joue un
énorme jeu de téléphone arabe à travers
les générations
en réaction à tout ce mélange
linguistique
quand j'étais petit je pensais je ne
veux parler une espèce de pot pourri des
langues
je me suis dit encore seulement si tout
le monde parle sa propre hollande et
bien moi aussi c'était une longue qui ne
me ressemblait à aucun autre longue
existence sur terre est la seule la
seule personne qui me comprenait c'était
ma mère en pensant qu'ils allaient me
motiver mon père me disait régulièrement
parler une autre langue vaut un million
de dollars à quoi je répondais à chaque
fois je préférerais plutôt avoir un
million de dollars tout de suite je
faisais le calcul avec en millions de
dollars tu peux facilement te payer un
cours intensif de langues étrangères est
à moi au moins 950 mille dollars qui te
reste certes dont le dans le cas des
cours à l'alliance française
il vous reste que cinq cent mille
dollars mais c'est que même une bonne
affaire dans notre côté ma mère
s'inquiétait pas mal à
concernant mon incapacité à répéter les
mots qui me disait un tel point que à
pouvoir si je n'étais pas mal entre
malentendants elle m'a emmené voir à
noël
aujourd'hui je ne sais toujours pas ce
que ces trois lettres veux le dire dans
le monde médical
mais il s'avère que c'est l'acronyme des
mecquois forme de pâte pressée veille on
y qui attira violet et légumes
vous voyez qu'on parle des nourritures
terrestres quand même après des tests il
sera vrai que je n'avais aucun problème
auditif
aujourd'hui je ne sais toujours pas si
ma mère était soulagé ou au contraire au
caucus inquiète après ce diagnostic
elle a dû se dire est ce que je préfère
que mon enfant soit handicapé de
l'oreille ou du cerveau c'est vrai qu'un
sou peut faire plein de boulot et gagner
beaucoup d'argent tandis que la seule
façon de réussir en tant qu'arrière oeil
ces derneirs président des états unis
c'était le moment politique de nice
bref en france après un stade où je
parlais comme un bébé
je suis passé par d'autres stades il ya
eu le stade vers 50 français où je
parlais assez bien pour que les gens
pensent que je comprends tout ce qu'ils
disent et donc ne font plus aucun effort
pour parler lentement et clairement du
coup moi je devais faire quoi que
j'avais compris du coup j'ai dû
maîtriser deux phrases des mimiques
assez passe partout qui pouvait marcher
dans tout le cas j'ai trouvé quant à bon
enthousiaste omv ont les sourcils les
miens je précise marché assez bien que
si la personne n'annonce la mort de son
père ou l'achat d'un jet ski ça s'est
passé pour tous après il a eu le stade
vers 8 ans français où je connaissais
pas mal de gros mots et je pensais je
prenais du plaisir à les employer
pourtant je ne lai sûreté par forcément
à bon escient
je me souviens qu'une fois j'étais sur
un vélib et quelqu'un m'a a failli
écraser avec sa voiture et moi je dis je
vais te faire de [ __ ] qui est plus une
promesse qu'une insulte
honnêtement et aujourd'hui
j'ai presque 13 ans français j'en suis
donc au stade ados où j'ai envie de me
rebeller contre tous si vous comprenez
pas mon français
alors c'est vous qui avez un problème ok
par mois en plus à l'âge que j'ai je
suis sur le point d'avoir la bar mitsva
français françaises
pour ceux qui ne savent pas une bar
mitzvah être un rituel juif ou à 13 ans
un garçon devient un nombre pour cela il
doit se présenter devant toute sa
famille ses amis et dieu et lire à haute
voix dans une longue qui connaît à peine
du coup ce discours aujourd'hui c'est un
peu comme un bar mais cela est content
pour ma bar mitzvah j'ai préparé ma
prestation à la dernière minute il y a
beaucoup de nourriture terrestre
par contre ce discours est bien moins
lucratifs comme madame edouard
alors même si je n'ai pas écrit ce
discours pour l'argent j'ai quand même
adoré le faire finalement je pense que
mon père avait raison
une langue vaut un million de dollars
effectivement
[Applaudissements]